-Face it.
-Face it!
-♪ Face It Challenge ♪
-Here's how it works.
Each round, we will draw a card,
which will tell us what face
we both have to make.
We'll look in our mirrors,
make our faces,
and reveal them
on the count of 3.
We'll stare at each other
for 10 seconds
while trying to hold our faces.
The first person
to crack a smile,
laugh, or break the face --
-You can't even get through that
without breaking.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, we're playing a game
where you can't break?
-I've never --
This is such a loaded game.
Let's see
what our first face is.
All right.
Ready?
Mug shot.
-Mug shot.
All right, ready?
-Yeah.
♪♪
[ Light laughter ]
-Okay, ready?
-Yep. -1, 2 --
-You going to count it out?
-Yep. 1, 2, 3.
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer ]
-[ Laughs ]
-Come on!
-I like a nice mug shot!
You don't have to be bummed out!
-That was a mess!
-Remember the one where it was
like, some guy in Congress --
He got a mug shot.
No, it's super happy.
You were like, "Oh, boy."
-Jim Morrison did
the cross-eyed one.
That was good.
All right, ready?
Just Bit into a Lemon.
[ Light laughter ]
-[ Chuckles ]
[ Laughter ]
1, 2, 3.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Buzzer ]
-[ Laughs ]
-I kind of feel like
we were both doing
de Niro a little bit.
-It was almost
a little Stan Laurel.
[ Both laugh ]
-Lot of chins in that one.
-Lot of chins.
-Lot of chins, yeah.
-So many chins.
-What do we got?
Guitar solo.
-Oh.
-Well, now,
you're a guitar player,
so, this might
be a little unfair.
-A little advantage
for this one.
-Now let's --
Should we make it --
Should we double down
on this?
Van Halen solo?
We do the Eddie Van Halen face?
-Yes.
-Okay.
Eddie Van Halen's face.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-1, 2, 3.
[ Guitar solo ]
[ Buzzer ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-That -- That is terrible.
I just saw --
I just saw "Hot For Teacher."
So, that's a great video.
-That's the greatest.
-What's it gonna be?
-Surprised fish.
-Like a fish that's like,
"Oh, no, I just got caught"?
-Yeah, surpri--
Or like a birthday party.
They're having a birthday party
for the fish, and it's like,
"Surprise!"
-"Surprise, Dave!"
-"Surprise, dude!
Happy birthday."
-Okay.
-Yeah.
Yeah. All right, ready?
This is the last one.
Here we go.
Surprised fish.
[ Light laughter ]
♪♪
Okay. Go.
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer ]
That's the great --
He got caught!
I got caught in my mouth!
-He got caught!
Jon Hamm, everybody!
Genius!
Kate Upton joins us
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.
Come on back!
♪♪